MEETING FOR THURSDAY JANUARY
THIRTIETH IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER PLEASE REVISE AN AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BE MADE. AS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED- I'VE CHECKED
HER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM. FLORA
THERE GRAYSON THERE HAVE NOT
MAY. MATHIS YOUR QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RIVAS WICKS HERE NUMBER
ONE WE HAVE A CALL HAVE
CONSENTED. FOR MOST OF THE
CONSENT AGENDA SOME OF THE
MOVERS CUNNINGHAM SECONDED BY
MS WHIPS A MAN CENTER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY
AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
CARILLO FLORA- FLOOR I GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA PROBLEMS
RIGHT RAMOS I RIVERSIDE
RIVERSIDE WICKS. HI WICKS I.
OKAY MOTION IS THANK YOU FOR
THAT MADE FOR MEN RAMPS AND
CALL. I BELIEVE THE AND RUNNING.